welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness a
movie that teaches us all a valuable
lesson about what happens when marvel
fans dream too big the scarlet witch
will break all your toys and make you
watch director sam raimi gave us the
mcu's first true horror film that also
rewrites the rules of the mcu in so many
cool ways so let's break down this movie
scene by scene for the incredible
attention to detail and deeper layer of
meaning that you might have missed also
we have a new multiverse of madness
inspired ladies obsession shirt that
looks amazing you gotta get your hands
on that one over at
newrockstarsmerch.com so the marvel
studios title card in this movie has
been updated the shots that previously
showed in-game moments have all been
replaced with wanda's scarlet witch
power-up and wandavision and various
shots of doctor strange from the 2016
film infinity war and end game the final
shot on the m of marvel studios is
strange's final scene in the 2016 film
but in the inner top of the r was
wanda's team up with her family in one
division so this is actually the first
time anything from a disney plus title
has made it into the title card just
proving how important wanda's experience
with their kids from that show is to
this movie also fun to note that behind
wanda's family in that shot is the west
view cinema with oz the great and
powerful plane a 2013 movie also
directed by sam raimi oz and its witches
definitely have parallels in this movie
story i'll get to that later the film
opens in the gap junction as defender
strange races with american chavez
toward the book of ashanti fleeing this
ribbony monster marked with runes later
we learn a puppet marionetted by the
scarlet witch merica chavez is a young
multiverse hopper from the comics who
comes from the utopian parallel and
you'll notice how the opening words
exchange in this film are in spanish
underlining chavez's role as the first
latina superhero of the mcu as well as
the first lgbtq plus superhero her star
emblazoned jacket has a pride flag pin
on it honor jacket has also written the
phrase amores amour spanish for love is
love now the book of vashanti also from
the comics is a book of positive
counterspells sharing its name with the
seal of vishanti the shape formed by the
window of the sanctum sanctorum now the
gap junction is later described as the
space between universes and here it's
presented as a sacred church-like plain
but now in ruins as if the damage
already done to the fabric of the
multiverse and titles like loki and
spider-man no way home have taken a toll
on this place and this week marvel had
kevin feige confirmed that the
multiversal crises of those titles
directly set the stage for the crisis of
this film the platform with the book on
it has 16 walkways converging out from
it many of them broken off a cool way of
showing how all the universes that
connected this are all backdoors leading
to this one book but many of those
universes and those pathways have
crumbled and eroded now defender strange
seems at first like the gallant to the
goofus that we've known multilingual
only using defensive spells like
freezing and binding hair tied back in a
ponytail like the chillest barista ever
but we learned the constant among all
strangers a willingness to sacrifice
friends in this case america he says
this is the only way and in the grand
calculus of the multiverse your
sacrifice before it gets cut off both of
these lines being callbacks linking this
strange variant to our doctor strange
who after sacrificing the time stoned
thanos infinity war told tony stark
there was no other way
and recently in spider-man no way home
told these exact words to peter parker
in relation to the deaths of norman
osborne and the rest being necessary in
the grand calculus of the multiverse
their sacrifice means infinitely more
than their lives but a fatally wounded
defender strange tumbles with america
through a star portal and the camera
work of sam raimi and director
photography john matheson rotate in a
really fun way so that we wake up with
our doctor strange in bed having seen
all of this as a dream now this movie
actually defines all of dreams as us
seen into the lives of our multiversal
selves a concept that has been explored
in real world metaphysics but in the mcu
poses some interesting questions were
the nightmares wanda gave the avengers
and age of ultron visions of other
universes tony's dream that he told
pepper about an infinity war last night
i dreamt
we had a kid
so real
we named him after your eccentric uncle
uh what was his name morgan
of course they would eventually have a
kid named morgan so tony's dream there
likely was an alternate universe so
strange glances over at his broken
wristwatch the one from the 2016 film
given to him by christine palmer and
broken by robbers outside comtaj a
watched face that he left broken to
reflect the unhealable wound of his
hands and his mastery of the mystic and
the mental over the physical in this
film the watch symbol evolves to
symbolize his forever broken
relationship with christine and how
that's actually okay strange uses magic
to tie his tie a reminder that his hands
are still damaged from his accident in
the 2016 film his hands truly are his
unhealable wound at the wedding he
passes this mom with two sons just a
little echo of the conflict that he's
about to face with wanda trying to
reunite with her sons who are roughly
the same age dr nick west returns to the
2016 film and reveals he too dusted in
the blip and lost two cats and oh yeah a
brother too he ponders if there could
have been any other path strange might
have taken infinity war and by having to
think about this strange faces that his
sacrifice play at the time stone while
it eventually led to the avengers being
able to fix things sort of in endgame it
also left survivors living with the
emotional toll of that conflict and in
wanda's case thanos using that same time
stone to render her heartbreaking
killing a vision meaningless strange
turns a glass of water into wine
freaking jesus over here also reminding
us of when he refilled thor's beer mug
in ragnarok really the best way to use
magic if you ask me strange apologizes
saying that he made sacrifices to
protect christine but that he's glad
she's happy really this whole movie is
the tug of war between sacrifice on one
hand and happiness on the other our
heroes begin this movie thinking that
sacrifice comes at the cost of personal
happiness but must learn by the end of
the film that sacrifice and what we
think we want is really how we find
deeper fulfillment and inner peace
strange here's a commotion outside and
tugs his red pocket square revealing it
as his cloak of levitation and he would
not believe the [ __ ] i got in trailer
breakdowns for theorizing that pocket
square was his cloak i love how he
summons it in free fall making this his
version of tony stark being caught by
the mark 7 armor while falling in the
avengers film now this beast is
initially invisible similar to how the
supernatural forces of moon knight are
initially invisible to onlookers but
strange decloaks it to reveal the squid
monster of gargantos a lesser-known
comics foe to namor the submariner and i
love how the animators used his single
eye to characterize him his surprise
when strange dismantles a bust his
eyelid creased to show anger his pupil
dilation when strange severs his
tentacle and of course the look of oh
[ __ ] when the eye is about to get
skewered now danny elkman's score
charges this whole film with a mad cap
feverish energy and here he uses some
great horns
[Music]
evoking missouri's night on bald
mountain aka the fantasia devil music
the back of the bus has an ad for la
llave coffee unlock a better day are
they being spanish for key a hint at
strange's upcoming quest to use his
watch to unlock the back door and also
this spanish-speaking superhero being
the key to his multiverse also nearby is
an ad for the magic of celestial tea and
when strange jumps on a taxi there's a
sign behind him for stan lee's which
might be a nod to stan lee whose real
name was stanley lieber and the 2008
hulk movie paid tribute to him with stan
lee's pizza wong shows up to try to
restrain gargantos gargantus uses one of
his suction cups to detach his canal
maybe showing how he does have some
defensive moves against the kinds of
attacks namor might hit him with he
scales the building sam raimi evoking
his sequence with doc ock scaling the
building in 2004 spider-man 2. meanwhile
back at the wedding behind christine and
charlie is a cameo by this movie
screenwriter michael waldron strange
uses his giant remote hands to use the
lamppost to javelin gargantos in the eye
and then pumps that eye out with its
connective tissue looking a lot like sam
raimi's hilarious flying eyeball in evil
dead 2. strange and wong mentioned their
recent deal with spider-man and no way
home and america asks if he shoots webs
out of his butt harvesting how tom
holland peter and andrew garfield peter
were both pretty grossed out by how toby
maguire peter's webbing came out of his
body a production design choice that was
actually made by sam rainey in that
initial series like does it just come
out of your wrists or
does it come out of anywhere else only
only the wrists now wait didn't strange
and wong forget about everything after
that movie's final memory wipe spell
well not exactly they only forgot who
peter parker is they still remember a
masked spider-man being part of their
history like notice here they never call
him peter parker and aren't really sure
how his webbing works just further proof
that he's just back to being a stranger
to them but they still know of a
spider-man existing in this universe
america shows them defender strange's
corpse on the sanctum roof and strange
buries him up there saying that he's
quote buried worse and i'm dying to know
who else in strange's life that he has
buried and where now they realize that
the matching runes on the two beasts was
witchcraft and so we returned to wanda's
kitchen in west view using the same
wanda vision episode 2 bewitched
inspired intro music just composed by
the lopez's in this kitchen they have a
hamster cage labeled max maybe short for
maxum off replacing poor sparky the dog
billy and tommy return here back to
wearing the same red and green colors as
wicken and speed do in the comics wanda
wakes up from this dream alone in her
bed and i love how the warm golden color
tone of the room shifts to a colder gray
as she sits up just another example of
dreams being windows into her alternate
selves then wanda prunes branches in an
apple orchard just really cool symbolism
here she says apples eventually as they
haven't yet borne fruit as her efforts
to produce a life with her sons has also
been fruitless she prunes errant
branches parallelly in the ways he who
remains in the tva would prune branch
timelines to exert control over the
multiverse kind of like how wanda has
been using the dark hole to x off
universes without her sons in them and
these being apples definitely reminds us
of the poisoned apple of the witch queen
of snow white which actually gets a
cameo later on in this film strange says
the flowers smell real and wanda claims
she put reality warping witchcraft
behind her after westview yet even here
the simulation seems real enough to
nearly full strange they chat what do
you know about the multiverse this had
his theories he believed it was
dangerous and then she drops the
branches in a crate labeled volkers or
bjolkers now in the comics wendell
volker is an academic who along with
reed richards discovers that baron zemo
has traveled back in time in a 2007
thunderbolt story i don't know maybe
this is on a sokovian estate that wanda
has overtaken temporarily somewhere
close to that mountain cabin we saw her
in wanda says there are other avengers
and strange mentions the archer with the
mohawk and several bug-themed crime
fighters of course referring to hawkeye
ant-man the wasp spider-man and possibly
now the scarlet scarab from moon knight
and he says we'll get you back on the
lunchbox there actually is a vintage
marvel superheroes lunch box with
spider-man cap and thor on the front
fantastic four in the back and on the
side scarlet witch daredevil and
yellowjacket wanted mistakes using
america's name when strange hadn't yet
so she drops the illusion that red hex
looking just as it did when it warped
the structures of west view and wanda
vision all of this coming from the dark
hold marvel's book of the damned which
wanda got from the witch out of the
harkness in wanovision this whole dead
landscape is likely near that mountain
cabin from the monovision post-credits
scene all the plants now rotting more
and more as the dark hole corrupts the
landscape and actually in the background
of this burnt orchard are the ruins of
some structure that was probably what
the large house was when the illusion
was up that structure might be the cabin
she was in in the one of vision post
credits scene wanda scarlet witch
wardrobe has evolved since we last saw
it in wanovision scratches radiate from
the heart region showing how her
fracturing of reality all stems from a
broken heart and the stitching on her
collar leaves an opening in the shape of
vision's mind stone reflecting how that
heartbreak began when she had to shatter
her love's mind in infinity war wanda
says america's sacrifice would be for
the greater good which strange says is
the justification of their enemies but
it's also essentially what defender
strange told america so when juana
criticizes strange for giving up the
time stone and infinity war so that
thanos could render her heartbreak and
sacrifice his revision pointless she's
totally right strange is a hypocrite
that doesn't seem fair back at commerce
wong explains that the scarlet witch was
prophesied to either rule or annihilate
the cosmos recalling what agatha read
from the dark holes your power exceeds
that of the sorcerer supreme
it's your destiny to destroy the world
commerce mounts its defenses master amir
returns to the 2016 film and we meet
sarah likely based on wong's romantic
partner of sarah wolf in the comics and
the minotaur sorcerer of rintra also
from the comics sorcerers from the hong
kong and london sanctums joined them
remember the 2016 film established the
three sanctums of earth being in new
york london and hong kong and behind
that one guy the portal to london has
one of the city's signature red phone
booths because that because that always
means london wanda arrives with a dark
cloud similar to the wicked witch of the
west attack on the emerald city writing
surrender dorothy and smoke this being
another witch demanding the magic girl
from another reality give herself up so
she could use her in her quest to power
actually you can map this whole movie
over the wizard of oz the shots of them
running along a brick road defender
strange being the brainless scarecrow
who ends up wobbling around puppeted our
strange the heartless tin man who cuts
wong the lion who gets his nerve the
illuminati of course the great and
powerful oz ultimately proving to be
total liars variant christine glenda the
good witch who ultimately teaches
strange that there is no place like his
home reality i mean the wizard of oz is
one of the coolest scariest and most
visually invented films of all time any
multiverse movie is right to follow its
lead wanda probes the kamatage barrier
and then finds a sneakier way in by
whispering into the mind of one sorcerer
similar to how she dismantled the
avengers in age of ultron by implanting
visions in their temples and just
freaking them out she blasts the hell
out of kamertage all of its artillery
and its archers leaving one poor
sorcerer in pain that she just
obliterates which seems cruel at first
but the guy was also in a lot of pain
you could also read as an act of mercy
strange trap swan on a mirror dimension
trap that ticks down with mechanical
music box music until the shards jab out
at her at this point juana's fingertips
have turned black the way agaves did in
wanovision when she used magic derived
from the dark hole they retreat into the
inner chamber where the camera glides
and distorts this door's slam remy
shoots all this with the same
claustrophobia and external evil trying
to break in that made the evil dead so
fun and like the possessed woman there
we only see the demon hands reaching up
to grab people which is also the kind of
imagery raymie used to drag me to hell
strange realizes wanda is using
reflective surfaces to get in and as
they rush to cover each mirror in puddle
on the first one that strange covers for
just a few frames remy sneaks in one of
wanda's eyes glaring up at strange
creepy wanda's eye returns to scare
america and then her hand reaches out
through the gong as she crawls in with
distorted limbs looking like the girl
from the ring strange unleashes serpents
from his hands looking similar than when
supreme strange absorbed and weaponized
in what if episode four and wanda begins
to drain america's power so strange
dives into america and they tumble
through the multiverse and it is insane
they pass a dimension with three cloaked
heads these are the faces of the living
tribunal the ultimate legal cosmic
entity in marvel lore who oversees
natural law of the multiverse with three
faces representing necessity equity and
revenge i like how here they are not on
the same head just three different heads
maybe away this universe in the fourth
dimensional space shows how they would
look from a fourth dimensional being in
the infinity gauntlet comics the living
tribunal acquitted thanos for snapping
away half of all life and the infinity
war writer said they actually drafted a
scene where strange and thanos would
have faced the living tribunal during
their wizard duel then they enter this
cosmic realm with all these curved paths
that snake back toward a glowing source
kind of looks like a mix of the
celestial's world forge and eternals but
i think we might be seeing cerebro
professor x's famous way of connecting
with all the minds of mutants then they
fall through a freaking beehive filled
with bees lined with honeycomb now we
later learned in this movie it was a b
landing on america's finger that first
triggered her fear and opened the star
portals that took her moms from her is
this what the hexagons and the beekeeper
from one vision were all about
can someone tell me please then they're
underwater beside a coral reef and some
of those fish swim out with them back in
the open air in new york where they pass
taxis with the ads grindhouse releasing
which is a company that remasters cult
films that partnered with sam raimi to
restore the evil dead and it's run by
bob marowski who also edited this movie
the next universe is a grid of techie
tubes it's actually filled with stark
drones from spider-man far from home
perhaps it's a reality where they
overthrew humanity then a hellish space
filled with bones true fire and
brimstone here strange runs into a pile
of skulls other skeletons are climbing
lampposts made out of spines all the
buildings are made of bones i mean i
would say this is just the mcu hill but
this movie also shows us like multiple
possible hells and moon knight did just
explain that the mcu afterlives of the
egyptian underworld and the wakandan
ancestral plane are actually part of the
same realm just subjectively taking the
form of whatever the believer believes
so these various hells might be part of
that same belief-oriented afterlife
system next a universe with a t-rex
fighting a triceratops then an animated
universe with some goofy marching band
music now this is not exactly the
animated style from what if and they do
pass that jonas and james sign so this
is actually the same spot where they
fought gargantos then this interesting
reality with the wreckage of some
propeller plane with green flames i
don't know i thought maybe this could be
the valkyrie plane from the first cat
film if it had made it to its intended
target of new york then a reality where
everything takes a cubic form i just
love how the break line between the
blocks separates on the teeth of
strange's open mouth then they shift
into sloshing paint reality where
america says she's been trapped in
before making it really hard to eat then
i love this an old-timey film
desaturated with wear on the celluloid
showing 1930s new york model t's the
brooklyn bridge in a blimp overhead this
is the world that steve rogers and bucky
barnes grew up in then this interesting
alien setting that also looks a bit
ancient because it includes a stonehenge
configuration remember thor the dark
world suggested stonehenge was part of a
coordinate layout to triangulate the
convergence so maybe this is the alien
society who helped lay out those
coordinates then two more futuristic
looking realities then a rocky volcanic
setting with lava rivers looking a lot
like mustafar from the star wars
universe actually in a similar montage
in what if episode 8 ultron infinity in
the watcher that also looked a lot like
mustafar and they land in dimension 838
a utopian manhattan covered with plant
life and wind turbines all built into
the skyscrapers the empire state
building has a waterfall coming from it
this actually seems like the direction
616 manhattan was going in the mcu with
far from home revealing a new atrium
constructed into the avengers tower and
various fantastic four hints at the
ground level all the advances of this
reality were almost certainly
innovations of reed richards they're on
the roof of the 838 sanctum you can
actually see the same greenhouse and
mound where defender strange was buried
back in 616. strange said he had been on
weird trips before of course referring
to the similar multiverse montage from
the 2016 film the world building of 838
is really cool all the citizens wear
monochromatic colors which might just be
a hint at the cold functionality of the
society the emphasis being on natural
beauty over the artificial kind of
beauty of fashion and just visually for
the sequence it helps strange in america
stick out like sore thumbs here also a
little detail i thought was interesting
if you look around pretty much everyone
is carrying an umbrella that might be
connected to those rainbow colored
clouds overhead which might be an
indicator that in this universe rain and
weather patterns are actually
artificially controlled scheduled on
clockwork coordinated by reed richards
maybe by aurora monroe storm as well a
measure that they take to help combat
climate change ensure plant life is
properly hydrated and the people who
live here just kind of have to deal with
rain being part of their lives all the
time of course the traffic colors are
reversed green for stop thus the x's red
for go thus the arrows now the fact that
838 proceeds on red when we would stop
does foreshadow how the foolish
illuminati is gonna proceed on the
scarlet witch when they definitely
should not our man bruce campbell cameos
sam raimi's star from the evil dead
films who cameoed in all three of his
spider-man movies and all those
characters were actually planned to be
mysterio quinton beck in sam raimi's
sports spider-man film before sony
canceled it here campbell's playing
pizza papa a vendor who sells pizza
balls time to deliver a pizza ball
strange curses his hand to punch himself
in the face for three weeks a nod to
ash's cursed hand and evil dead two a
memory lane bank reveals the flashbacks
of christine giving steven that watch
and america's origin losing her mothers
in the utopian parallel but in the
comics this was not america's fault or
even the bee's fault and really her
mother sacrificed themselves and ended
up disintegrating to becoming part of
the universe but here in the mcu it's
hinted that her moms might still be
alive so they arrive at the 838 sanctum
and the statue of supreme strange which
has been built out into the street from
the sidewalks the cars have to go around
it and i'll look at it and pay respect
the plaque reads dr steven strange gave
his life to feeding thanos we express
eternal gratitude to earth's mightiest
hero earth's mighty ciro of course the
nickname for the avengers and comics
there's a rare book shop on the other
side of the street called mcclouds which
could be a nod to comics writer bob
mccloud who co-created the new mutants
with chris claremont mordo returns the
2016 film strange says mordo dedicated
his life to trying to kill him referring
to that movie's post-credits scene where
mordo turned against all sorcerers too
many sorcerers
we never got to see any real conflict
between them since that moment mordo
confirms darkholds exist in every
universe and explains the concept of
dreamwalking projecting one's
consciousness into one's alternate self
and over this raymie shows
cross-dissolving montages of wanda's
ritual the visuals evoke the dream
sequence of rosemary's baby there's
surrealism superimposed shots close-ups
of the eyes and i love how danny elfman
scores this with rock we hear some drums
electric guitar really this is the sound
of witchcraft in the 90s to me like the
craft buffy the vampire slayer i very
much dig it but mordo drugged the tea
with green powder that also powers the
cuffs called the sands of nisanti a
spell from the comics that prevents the
usage of magic for three minutes wanda
dreamwalks into another universe's west
view house the camera voyeuristically
glides in and peeks out from behind the
staircase these point of view shots
evoking john carpenter's opening shots
of halloween the way wanda creeps in
here is very much like a stalker like
michael myers now billy and tommy are
watching on the tv a black and white
cartoon of oswald and ortenzia a 1928
walt disney short called the sky
scrappers now walt disney made oswald
shorts for universal before contract
dispute led to him launching mickey
mouse and steamboat willie so oswald has
actually gained a cult following over
the years as the mickey who could have
been and i just love how he shows up
here in this alternate universe now
secret cameos and surprise twists are
pleasant surprises when you're watching
a new marvel movie just like getting a
discount code on your online shopping is
a welcome surprise and that's where
today's sponsor honey comes in honey is
the number one shopping tool in america
it's the free tool that scours the
internet for coupon codes and
automatically tests them at checkout of
all your favorite websites here at new
rockstars producer zach just moved
houses and while he's been waiting to
unpack his kitchen he's been hitting
food delivery hard and saving a bunch of
money using honey get honey on your
computer for free and two easy clicks
then when you're checking out on your
favorite sites honey pops up and all you
have to do is click apply coupons wait a
few seconds as honey searches for
coupons on that site and if honey finds
a working code you will watch the prices
drop when there's a coupon honey finds
discounts of 18
on average 17 million people are saving
money with honey and it's got over one
hundred thousand five star google
reviews take it from me if you have a
computer honey really should be on it
get honey for free by going to
joinhoney.com
new rockstars that's join honey.com new
rockstars so they know that i sent you
and thanks honey for sponsoring today's
video a birthday photo of wanda turns to
stare at her especially creepy since the
champagne is still frozen mid-spill the
peas roll around on the plate evoking
the way the food squirmed around in the
kitchen in poltergeist an ocean churns
in the coffee cup an early sign of the
incursions that dream walking risks an
ocean similarly crashed through the
post-incursion universe of sinister
strange and a dreamwalking wanda takes
control of this wanda giving us this
chilling moment when elizabeth olsen
looks directly at the camera breaking
the fourth wall as if to tell all of us
i see you it's just a really spooky
horror trope that we've seen in the
closing shots of horror films like
psycho and paranormal activity sarah
breaks wanda out of this dreamwalking
state by stabbing the darkhold and sarah
burns crying a single tear so one it
turns to torturing rintra and the others
to get wong to confess that the darkhold
was actually a copy of the spells carved
into the walls of the temple on mount
wondergore which in the comics was a
place where the demon cathan inscribed
the spells that were eventually drafted
into the darkhold book this is also the
mountain where in some comics wanda and
pietro were actually born in the castle
of the high evolutionary we got a nod to
that comic backstory in one division
with a sighting of bova milk bova being
one of the high evolutionaries annie men
who nursed wanda and pietro wundegor
mountain is where cathon initially
cursed wanda as a baby though in the 616
mcu want a vision established that she
was born to arena in oleg maximoff in
sokovia though in that flashback wanda
showed she already had as a girl
low-level probability hex capabilities
so it remains to be seen if the mcu will
trace that back to cathodon's curse or
if they're going to define wanda as a
mutant or both wong takes wanda to that
temple where the walls are carved to
look exactly like the scarlet witch page
of the dark hole that we saw in juan
division episode nine this temple is
guarded by hulking creatures that may be
based on the ingary c'than's elder spawn
minions from the comics but when they
take a knee wanda realizes that the
chamber isn't a tomb but a throne the
altar she stands on is actually carved
with that same horned head figure as we
saw on the dark hold cover this is
perhaps the horned form of c'thon from
the comics meanwhile variant christine
explains that they are in dimension 838
and she has designated strange's home
universe as 616. 616 is the numerical
designation of the primary universe in
the comics and until now the mcu has
really been considered earth 19999 based
on a joke by kevin feige that he planned
for the mcu to run for that many years
but now it is firmly codified as 616
which was hinted at in the tva's film
strip in loki episode 1 and an easter
egg on a storage locker and end game and
interestingly mysterio's line from far
from home there are multiple realities
peter this is earth dimension 616. i'm
from earth 833 now quentin bank was
lying in that moment he was reciting a
script written by guterman so it's just
a total uncanny coincidence that they
chose the correct numerical designation
or maybe guterman is a tva agent
no probably not now christine compares
616 steven to 838 steven using his hand
injuries a kind of multiversal
fingerprint so like for peter parker
losing a parent figure and the with
great power quote are absolute constants
for those variants their hand injuries
are the constant and on that screen you
can see stephen cell is d23 which is a
disney easter egg d for disney 23 for
1923 the year walt disney founded his
animation studio christine says that
this is the baxter foundation and not of
course to the baxter building
headquarters to the fantastic four in
the comics strange speculates that this
could be part of the avengers or shield
or hydra hydra was an organization that
was tracking strange since 2014's
captain america winter soldier what
targets
you bruce banner steven strange anyone
who's a threat that being the first time
we're at stephen strange mission in the
mcu but morto declares the illuminati
will see you now the illuminati in the
marvel comics is a six-member group of
leaders representing different super
factions you got tony stark leader of
the avengers charles xavier leader of
mutant kind reed richards leader of the
fantastic four doctor strange sorcerer
supreme black bolt leader the inhumans
and neymar king of atlantis as is the
case here though their med lane often
gets in their own way serving the
illuminati are these ultron sentries
which are actually voiced by actor ross
marquan who voiced ultron in what if in
red skull infinity war now the baxter
foundation hq is in central park of 838
manhattan and the interior is modeled on
the lobby of the british museum of
london mordo introduces the 838
illuminati lineup including himself
naming himself baron carl mordo the
character's name from the comics strange
dodges the union jack shield of captain
carter leader of the 838 avengers played
by hayley atwell looking just as she
does and what if so presumably there are
other avengers in this 838 universe then
there's captain marvel maria rambo
defender of the cosmos lashanna lynch
returning from the 2019 captain marvel
film presumably from a history where
maria not carol danvers was irradiated
by that light speed engine then black
agar bolt gun aka black bolt leader of
the inhumans and keeper of the terrigen
mist ons amount reprises the role from
abc's short-lived inhuman series now and
humans are superpower genetic
experiments created by the cree who live
on the moon black bolts voice releases a
powerful sonic blast so the guy rarely
talks here he's seen with this tuning
fork headgear from the comics terrigen
miss meanwhile is the cree technology
that creates inhumans via cocoon we
actually saw this process with quake in
agents of shield intelligent mist may
tie into miss marvel since that is how
kamala khan gets her powers in the
comics though the disney plus series may
be going in a different direction but of
course reed richards aka the elastic mr
fantastic of the fantastic four played
by fan cast dreamboat john krasinski i
like how he teleports in via the square
portal which is a completely new kind of
tech than we've seen in the mcu seems
very much like the kind of tech richards
and dr doom used in the comics strange
asks if the fantastic four quote charted
in the 60s of course comparing them to
the beatles similar to the way bruce
banner talked about the avengers
infinity war broke up
like a band like like the beatles and
the way toby and andrew thought the
avengers was a band and no way home well
you don't have the avengers is that a
bad are you in a band now strange is
probably just joking but ant-man
director peyton reed did pitch doing a
fantastic four movies set in the 60s
like the beatles movie a hard day's
night and many of us have speculated
that the fantastic war could have
existed in the 60s of the 616 mcu
contemporaries of a younger hank pym the
way that in the silver age comics the
fantastic four and hank pym ant-man all
kind of work together now reed explains
that strange's arrival in 838 risks an
incursion which is determined marvel
comics for when universes collide like a
series of incursions between earth 616
and the ultimate universe of 1610 the
universe of miles morales is what led to
the 2015 secret wars event when all
these variant heroes and villains met in
dr doom's battle world which is why many
believe that the mcu might be headed
toward a similar event in a fifth
avengers crossover film the villain of
which in this case might be kang the
conqueror because we saw what may have
been incursions in the mcu in miss
minute's intro video in loki episode 1
and kevin feige just confirmed that loki
and sylvia killing that kang variant he
who remains led to the sacred timeline
unraveling into various incursions and
that's really what set the stage for the
crisis of this movie and remember the
original kang variant nathaniel richards
was a 31st century descendant of reed
richards so really this is all connected
and of course the sixth member of this
illuminati floats in professor charles
xavier with patrick stewart returning
for the fox x-men franchise we should
tell him the truth but rather than the
exact character from those films which
do have their own convoluted timeline in
which charles dies in logan this charles
has a yellow hover chair a green suit
the blue and black tie looking exactly
as he does in the 90s animated series
actually if you listen closely the music
of this moment is ron wasserman's theme
music from that series
also when they introduce captain carter
they bring in alex of esther's captain
america theme now there is one more
chair that's left empty on this
illuminati deus suggesting some past
seventh member or just an extra chair
that they keep open now those ultron
centuries might suggest a variant iron
man since it was his tech that led to
this appearance of ultron in the 616 mcu
then again in the comics it was hank pym
who created ultron so that seventh seat
could be his but also in the comics the
illuminati originally reached out to
t'challa the black panther who ended up
deciding not to join the group that
might be his seat and the ultron
centuries were just created by reed
richards so they finally revealed the
truth that during their infinity war
conflict with thanos 838 steven used the
dark hole to try to find a solution in
the multiverse but in doing so
accidentally caused an incursion that
killed everyone in that alternate
universe now reed does say that 838
steven never told them the details so
there's probably more to that backstory
now charles uses telepathy to thank
goodness show not tell taking us to the
day they beat thanos using the book of
ashanti look closely at thanos's corpse
yikes his double-bladed uber blade is
broken and plunged into his chest and
importantly his gauntlet does not yet
have all the stones we see the power
stone space stone reality stone and soul
stones but the mind stone is missing
which tells us that vision may still be
alive in 838 838 strange's fingertips
are black showing the darkhold's
corruption on his soul just like we saw
on the fingers of wanda in agatha
blackbolt whispers i'm sorry i like how
his voice echoes louder and louder with
onson mount recording multiple versions
of this line building up to a complete
shout to school of showing how that
sonic blast obliterates strange wanda
uses the dark temple to dreamwalk into
838 wanda's house i like that little
detail of her knocking over the dominoes
but this also confirms to us that in the
838 dimension wanda had that perfect
life with billy and tommy so the mind
stone being missing from thanos's
gauntlet and vision survival might have
been the key difference there so this
possessed wanda attacks the baxter
foundation and charles tells stephen to
get to the book of ashanti and he says
just because someone stumbles and loses
their way doesn't mean they're lost
forever which is a direct quote from
2014's x-men days of future past when
charles said this line to his younger
self just because someone stumbles loses
their way it doesn't mean they're lost
forever now that movie ended with
charles in his first hover chair we saw
in live-action film so who knows maybe
that restored timeline from days of
future past didn't lead to logan it
could have led to this and then after
finishing off the ultrons wanda marches
in covered in their oil like it is blood
recalling that dark moment in age of
ultron when she ripped out ultron's
heart and just let it bleed that oil the
oil streaks on her face totally evokes
[ __ ] spacek and carry which totally
influences the blood bath wanda
unleashes here also the way her hand
bursts out of the darkness later in her
mind reminding us of brian de palma's
final shot of that movie reed says that
he has children of his own and that
their mother is alive referring to susan
storm the invisible woman and their
children franklin richards and valeria
richards in confirming that lineage that
will one day lead to nathaniel richards
kang wanda erases blackbolt's mouth like
neo in the matrix and folks this is the
most horrific death we have seen in the
mcu and i hate to do this but we gotta
go through it here just think about it
black bolt does not have to scream the
guy spends most of his time not at all
using his vocal cords but it's just the
panic of his mouth being erased that
rattles him to his core so he ends up
making the worst possible mistake of
vocalizing anything that scream
ricochets around his jaw you can see it
glowing on the other side of his skin
until it amplifies and amplifies and
goes back into his brain blood blowing
out of his nose his eyes bulging a bit
and his skull blows out the back then
caving in and then brains oozing out the
side as his tuning fork flickers out god
almighty then reed makes the mistake of
attacking and wanda unravels his elastic
body into ribbons and then pops his head
like a pinata so then peggy and maria
jump in peggy using jetpack thrusters
that she presumably got from reed peggy
spits out some blood and then quotes
cap's iconic line of i can do this all
day but then poor peggy gets severed at
the midsection by your own shield
actually if you look closely after that
shield goes through peggy is still
initially in one piece but as the camera
refocuses on the shield in the
foreground her blurry form in the
background slumps forward but in two
halves and then wanda collapses a statue
on maria at least for maria it can be an
open coffin i mean each of these four
actors must have been directed on how to
emote their own deaths but there is no
way all these actors were on set with
each other or told how each other would
die because they should be screaming and
horror otherwise these four must be
pretty desensitized to people dying this
way charles enters wanda's mind depicted
as a white void where he's able to walk
he was a black turtleneck and beyond
that door is a pile of rubble including
the tv set playing the intro to one
division episode one air sirens raid in
this rebels clearly the rebel that wanda
and pietro were buried under in sokovia
when stark warhead landed in their home
but the scarlet witch's red cloud closes
in and she snaps his neck making this
the third time we have had to see
patrick stewart charles xavier die now
all these marvel heroes coming together
to try to stop the scarlet witch who
does not care who she hurts that she
tries to be with her kids or block
points inspired directly by the house of
m comic event but whereas that story
goes deeper and deeper into x-men lore
make some major moves on whether or not
they even exist in reality this movie's
connections to mutant kind stop right
here so strange american christine flee
as wanda chases them her eyes glowing
red looking a lot like her zombie form
from those episodes of what if they find
the hatch the waypoint in the book of
ashanti but it is locked requiring a
special key strange's wristwatch given
them to him by christine another
absolute element shared by all strangers
so they get to the book of ashanti in
the gap junction but wanda attacks and a
page from the book burns out showing a
star if you look closely so remember the
dark hold page showed the scarlet witch
this book shows america chavez's symbol
proof that the girl was destined to be
the perfect antidote to the dark sorcery
of the scarlet witch and strange sees
this page burn which is how he knows
what to tell america in that final act
strange and christine get banished to a
post-incursion universe which slowly
melts that melting looking a lot like
the way reality eroded in what if
episode 4 after strange broke an
absolute point and they passed a
floating honey beige 1973 oldsmobile
delta 88 the same car sam raimi puts in
all of his movies it was uncle ben's car
in the spider-man movies and appeared in
the evil dead series and in drag me to
hell now you'll notice this incursion
universe has two red streaks racing
through it the same color as that
looming crescent shape beyond the
sanctum stairway now kids what are
crescents crescents of course are formed
by the shadow of the earth on the moon
from the light of the sun behind us so i
wonder if this crescent could be this
dead world's shadow being cast on the
other world that collided into it maybe
earth 838 the reality of 838 strange
that collided into this universe the
dimension of sinister strange that could
have been the unseen annihilation that
the illuminati referred to 838 strange
might have used the dark hole to
dreamwalk into sinister strange and
sinister strange tried to cast him out
and that war between the two dragged
their worlds together in a way that
killed everyone and sinister strange's
universe that could bend the war that he
lost that he was talking about and the
guilt over winning that war might have
been what 838 strange confessed to the
rest of the illuminati and now these two
streaks might represent the lifelines of
those two universes synced forever
parallel but never touching yet still
way too close i mean the creepiest
detail about this place is the fact that
a freaking field of bones stretches in
front of the sanctum everyone in this
reality died from an incursion but no
human remains are visible anywhere else
that means that these unfortunate souls
of this universe led to the sanctum
looking for sanctuary begging this
strange to save him and he watched as
they died strange brings up their dead
sister donna whom he says fell in the
ice when they were kids in the comics
donna drowned after getting a cramp in a
swimming pool sinister strange reveals a
third eye on his forehead now strange
sometimes has the third eye in the
comics as a manifestation of the eye of
agamotto a way of showing the mystical
sight that the ancient one referred to
when she touched this spot on his head
open your eyes
but in this case the third eye
represents the twisted evil of the
darkhold the curse of kathan living on
these two strangest duel sinister
strangest sorcery is purple the same
color of agatha's magic the color of the
dark dimension and dormammu which is
something that's going to play a very
big role as dormammu's niece clea shows
up in the post-credits scene to work
with a strange with three eyes during
the fight strange grabs the piano making
that same horror music sting that up
until now in this movie has meant fear
but instead now he weaponizes the fear
to lift the music notes off the page
each note making the same note it would
if you were to play it on the piano i
love this music duel so much swedish
strange blocks the notes by conjuring
the five lines of a scale which is how
you would contain loose notes and sheet
music and forming a new arrangement
which plays as johan sebastian box
famous organ chords
[Music]
[Applause]
strange launches sinister strange out
the window impaling them on the fence
like saruman but the third eye still
opens because the evil lives so strange
now uses the dark hole to dreamwalk into
the one strange still left in 616 the
buried defender strange resurrecting the
corpse now remember earlier wong told
wanda that no sorcerer can pass the
barrier to whitagor temple so those
souls of the dam that attack defender
strange are not just an obstacle using
them by turning them into a new cloak is
literally the only way strange could fly
over there that's just a really smart
example of what screenwriters call
economy of story repurposing story
elements we thought were just set
dressing or characterization or raised
stakes like the defender strange corpse
the watch strange scene a star page in
the book of ashanti these souls of the
damned and instead giving them new
practical functions for the hero to
advance so when a bunch of nerds in your
movie theater started applauding in this
moment going yes it isn't just because
we love sam raimi's zombie [ __ ] i mean
we do it's because this moment was a
culmination of all these seeds that were
planted throughout the movie now when
the souls of the damned attacks
christine she banishes them with the
breezier of bomb goliath the same
artifact strange tried to use on
kaiselius in the 2016 film you don't
know how to use that do you
ah
yeah so that is why gaisel is hesitated
that thing could have banished him to
hell strange arrives with the damned
soul cape and wanda says dreamwalking
you hypocrite the same thing kaiselius
shouted at the ancient one when she used
dark dimension magic hypocrite now
realizing america's power is needed to
beat wanda strange repeats this is the
only way so once again we have looped
back to the opening scene a defender
strange must once again face this moral
quandary of sacrifice in america this
time though america accepts her fate so
why does strange now make a different
choice what has changed what makes this
strange different well this strange
trusts america to control her own power
because every portal she opened in this
film has brought them to where they
needed to go remember this is the same
strange who looked at 14 million six
century five paths and found the one
correct path for his life and so unlike
all the other strangers who are always
seeking a better life including 838
strange who looked in a different
universe for one our strange finally
realizes he has gratitude for the path
that he is on because folks the true
ideal of america is not the pursuit of
happiness it's gratitude for what we
have so america punches wanda first into
hell i love that that's where she thinks
she needs to go but america learns that
the better destination for wanda is just
to give the woman what she wants her
west view home where her sons actually
see her true nature now based on the
other wandest bruises this is actually
838 the same wanda that she possessed
earlier interesting how now on the tv is
snow white in the seven dwarves remember
in the alt universe there was an alt
universe walt disney short starring
oswald the lucky rabbit but in this one
it's the iconic walt disney first
feature length animated film snow white
and seven dwarves also remember a story
with an evil witch queen that haunted me
as a little kid so these poor boys are
on pins and needles about an evil witch
queen coming in through a portal into
their living room and despite being
possessed into doing horrible things
this other wanda forgives the scarlet
witch assuring her that these boys will
be loved telling the mother what she
needs to hear and so wanda collapses the
temple on herself and she destroys the
dark holes in every reality and while it
seems like 616 wanda may be dead we do
still have this other wanda who was
there for all the craziest [ __ ] that
happened in this movie awanda who
remember shares this 838 reality with
mutants with the fantastic four so some
version of the house of m no more
mutants moment may be on the way in the
mcu in the final scenes of this movie
strange gets closure with christine he
leaves america in training at camertaj
and finally gives sorcerer supreme wong
the bow he deserves and most importantly
he finally fixes the broken watch the
camera transitioning from the broken
lens to clarity but that clear vision
proves itself a curse in the final shot
of the film the man is seen too well
with three eyes as the curse of the dark
gold lives on it's a scarlet letter for
his sins and a new unhealable wound for
the surgeon to suffer now i broke down
the post-credit scenes in another video
and we got lots of multiverse madness
videos coming down the pipeline so
subscribe for more takes on this insane
film and hey if you live in the san
francisco bay area i'm back performing
comedy live with end games improv at the
stage works theater 446 valencia
straight in the mission my first show
coming saturday may 14th then after that
every other saturday at the same space
coming out with me it'll be fun you can
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos following the rockstars and
subscribe to rockstars for more analysis
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you